as far as bungee is concerned destiny is
a shooter first and foremost but it has
role-playing elements you can find loot
and upgrade your gear your character and
your weapons earn experience level up
and get new abilities over time there
are three classes the somewhat mystical
warlock the hefty Titan and the sneaky
hunter the classes have different skills
but any class can use any weapon
borrowing from MMOs destiny has six
person endgame raids it also has smaller
three-person missions called strikes but
Bungie also wants those players who
prefer playing solo to be able to have a
great experience you'll see other
players in the world and public events
give you a reason to work with them to
achieve a common goal but you can keep
doing your own thing and ignore them if
you choose in my brief time with destiny
the game felt good but also familiar in
gameplay terms it seems to be covering a
lot of the same territory that
Borderlands covers I'm hoping that the
game's universe and its lore can help
set it apart from other games but for
now there's a lot we still don't know
for instance destiny will have a big
player versus player component but
bungee is waiting until e3 to reveal any
details about that aspect of the game
stay tuned to gamespot for all the
latest on destiny